the writers are off the picket line the
strike's over right well
no but we're headed that way so what
currently happened is the wga the writer
scale of America reached a tentative
agreement with the amptp now that's not
finalized it still has to be ratified
but it is a step in the right direction
assuming that the rest of the Union
signs off on it which is expected to
happen then that will end the writers
strike
keep in mind though that's not the only
strike going on there's still the actors
strike and so as far as impact on my
particular Channel and how I have
limited some of the content that I'm
doing nothing changes because I wasn't I
wasn't doing it to support only one of
the two unions I was doing my
alterations to my content to support
both so until both strikes are fully
wrapped up
same restrictions so if you're still
waiting for me to talk about the Doctor
Who anniversary special trailer
I'm not gonna sorry it's promotional
material I'll still review the episodes
though don't worry